voilà monsieur bonsoir la première
information de ce dimanche soir vient de
budapest le gouvernement hongrois vient
de décider en effet d'autoriser les 6500
citoyens est-allemands réfugié sur son
territoire à le quitter pour la
destination de leur choix
collectivement individuellement par tous
les moyens qu'ils voudront cette
décision prendra effet à minuit ce soir
et l'on sait que principalement ces
hommes et ces femmes ont l'intention de
se rendre en allemagne de l'ouest où les
autorités ont annoncé dès la semaine
dernière qu'elle était prête à les
accueillir à bonn on estime que ces
quelques milliers de personnes ne
représentent que le début d'une
émigration qui pourrait d'ici à quelques
années s'amplifier pour atteindre le
chiffre de 1 voire 2 millions véronique
taveau la liberté enfin ils vont pouvoir
partir quitter la hongrie et c'est quand
passer à l'ouest
ce moment les réfugiés des camps de
budapest l'attendait depuis plusieurs
semaines il aura fallu de longues
négociations entre l'allemagne de l'est
l'allemagne de l'ouest et la hongrie
pour parvenir à un accord ce soir leurs
riffs cède aux pressions internationales
et une grosse et frontières les fonds
ainsi partir des ressortissants d'un
autre pays laisse d'un pays frère un
fait sans précédent à partir de minuit
trois postes frontière entre la hongrie
et l'autriche vont être spécialement
ouvert ce soir
pas besoin de visa les réfugiés sont
même autorisés à partir avec leur propre
voiture
les convois la liberté comme ils les ont
eux mêmes baptisée vont enfin passer à
l'ouest
pour les milliers de réfugiés une
nouvelle vie commence
de l'autre côté en allemagne de l'ouest
tout est prêt pour les recevoir la
bavière s'apprête à accueillir le plus
grand exode de réfugiés en europe depuis
la construction du mur de berlin en 1961
il ya quelques minutes à peine le
ministre des affaires étrangères ouest
allemand monsieur dietrich genscher a
déclaré ce soir donc son pays
l'oublierai pas cette décision de la
hongrie décisions courageuses dit-il
prise sous sa propre responsabilité